[Music]
how's it hanging reject nation it's John
coming at you with another music video
reaction got some new songs here from
Mike Shinoda of Linkin Park coming out
with some new stuff for his new solo
effort post tramatic which if you
remember started off as a three song EP
and now is going to become a 16 track
full-length album and in sort of honor
of the announcement of that Mike debuted
two new songs crossing a line as well as
nothing makes sense anymore two brand
new songs and two brand new music videos
so I thought I would check those out
today as always a quick disclaimer
before we hop into this cannot show the
full uncut videos here have to pare them
down a little bit otherwise they get
blocked well why don't nobody gets to
hear anything at all and that's not
ideal and that's no joke cuz I have
literally reacted this video three times
in order to get it up on YouTube so so
if you want to see the full uncut stuff
come on over to our patreon got a lot of
other cool stuff over there too
full-length TV show watch alongs
exclusive videos and delete it takes
weekly Q&A is a good community of people
it's a lot of fun so come check us out
over there let's go for it
here we go this first song is called
crossing a line hitting
since okay at the old Tower Records oh
wow
red flannel
[Music]
[Music]
damn
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hence the first time I heard that right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
people know the song now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right all right not bad not bad
[Music]
funny enough I actually saw the
Instagram post that went out this music
video was shot very recently actually he
put out just a picture just a call on
Instagram for anybody who wanted to come
out and be involved with something a
little special to come out to the old
Tower Records in Hollywood man I would
have gone had there not been a bunch of
stuff to do that evening but I like what
he's doing with this new solo album
cycle it seems like I mean I like what
he's building on with these sounds this
is a popular tune perhaps then the three
that made it on to the EP and I know
people have said this is kind of their
less favorite of the two songs here but
I thought this song had a really nice
build
I like the Tambor that he's working with
and especially given the poor reception
that one more light initially had I feel
like this song is refining and using
some of those pop sensibilities in a
more interesting way at least based off
that first impression I got I listened
to the album back when it first came out
and it wasn't exactly my cup of tea
still been meaning to pick up a copy and
actually like give it a listen given the
context of all that has happened since
its dropped but just looking at this
song I mean I really like the build and
I love the rawness that he's bringing to
this and even though this isn't the
crabbiest song he's released so far I
would imagine that in context of the
album it will flow pretty well as one of
the different facets I like the
production choices he's making here
especially in the earlier parts it
almost feels like the song ought to be
backwards or something with the way
things are syncopated I like the
instrumentation that he brings here I
mean at least the EP stuff he said he
kind of played everything on that and I
get the sense that's what's going on
here and I like the choices he's making
I like the instruments the sounds I like
the subtle guitars you get in there
later on in the track and I like like I
said the build and the sort of crescendo
is special at the end I think he's got a
good grasp on the grooves of this and
the punch of this so I am excited to get
into the next one second song on here is
called nothing makes sense anymore as
the official music video as well I got
my headphones stuck in my hair
here we go whoa
I remember this man
we were downwind of this situation
it's like Silent Hill that day
everything was just ashen fog
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
damn
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
alright alright not bad I like the way
that that track builds and and I there
are no drums yeah I think that's pretty
cool this is interesting to did to go
back to the fire cuz yeah I was a that
was a big that was a big week oh boy
yeah I remember the day that that
happened or at least the day that
started we woke up and and just the
outside world was gray there was ash
everywhere it was raining ash into the
courtyard of our apartment complex it
was it was kind of everywhere all over
this area of California that was a
pretty intense time and especially to
see that sort of cacophony happening
around the time you know given the
context of this given what we know Mike
is processing and was going through
while he was probably recording that
while he was working on all this it's
pretty striking and I liked the way he's
jumping off from those first videos that
he did for this those little cell phone
videos in his studio and at home and
whatnot and I like that he's building on
that here I feel like the look has sort
of grown especially piggybacking off
that third video from the first cycle
this has a lot of cool superimposed
images and it kind of builds the similar
way that the song does is the song is
sort of going on building momentum
gathering parts and different sounds and
sort of stacking them on top of each
other and building the intensity that
way the video kind of follows suit
because you have all these little
details and these little personal
moments of him singing along with the
song and then they start to overlap and
superimpose one another in these really
striking visuals that do sort of equate
to the cacophony and the turmoil that is
being sort of hinted at through these
lyrics especially you know partway
through halfway through when that really
became focal I thought this video really
came together both of these songs feel
kinda on the brief so I don't know I
guess this is about four minutes but
yeah I just like the attention to detail
and I I do like oddly the intimate
quality these videos have it's like
nothing you couldn't have shot on an
iPhone or something I imagine that's
probably how this happened but just the
choices here and the the overlapping
it's really visual in a very simple but
effective way I think and the sentiments
of both these songs you know kind of
again out of that EP I really like what
he's doing here just because I think
despite again you'd always trade back a
tragedy like that above like the you
know passing of Chester and all the
ripples that have come out of the wake
of that but at the same time I feel like
it has catapulted Mike at least into
making some very lucid and very
heartfelt and very compelling new songs
that are borrowing from the sounds that
we associate with him but it also has
his own sort of quality on it and
especially it's not being Fort Minor
it's just being Mike Shinoda I like that
we've gotten a glimpse of his rapping in
this context as well as his singing
these are both singing oriented songs I
mean his sense for Ryan is still there
but on these two tracks he showcases two
kind of different approaches to singing
and layering of those vocals and I like
what he's doing here and I'm feeling
like this album as a whole is probably
gonna be an interesting experience he
said it's sort of documentary the
journey through and out of hopefully
grief and that's all very apparent in
the lyrics to both of these songs and
especially in the first one you know I I
may say that I don't care anymore but
know that that's not true kind of
touching on these weird things that we
do and say when we're grieving and the
feelings that we have this sort of
despondence and whatnot when the world
is upside down and that too you know
some of those literal shots were Mike or
these landscapes the fire are not only
superimposed but also upside down making
this really disorienting and whatnot I'm
really excited to hear this album and I
feel like this could be something really
special I mean I've liked every track
I've heard off of it so far
I think the post-traumatic BP is perhaps
a bolder collection of songs but
especially as the Harbinger for the
actual album now I thought these two
were cool and I think it's nice that he
decided to showcase a different side of
the album's sound because we already
know the darker the harsher sounds as
well as that first track off the EP was
not quiet but but on a more soft side of
the spectrum a more gauzy side of the
spectrum and these are a little bit more
toothy than that one was so I'm liking
the range of sounds I like you know sort
of the expression Mike is pulling
together here and I just I like what he
sounds like when he's on his own in
processing things again like
I really wish things could have been
different however I think that something
special is poised to come out of that
and that's kind of all you can hope for
given what life throws your way
sometimes it goes to exemplify that idea
that art can be one of the most
effective and the most lucid and one of
the most major ways of coping with
trauma and grief and just the things
life throws at you so I wish I could
have gone out to that first taping cuz
yeah they just recorded that one evening
a couple weeks ago down in Hollywood
that sort of intimate quality to see all
those people gathered around mikeís or
sharing this moment I'm imagining that's
the first time they heard that song and
then all kind of singing it together by
the end of the video seeing the
different tattoos people are rocking of
the different lyrics or or of Chester's
face you know the images of Chester just
seeing the love that's one thing that
over the years I've always gotten the
sense for and I've always appreciated
about Linkin Park and just their
projects in general it's like say what
you will you know you have your taste
whatever it is you know even if you hate
Linkin Park you've got to feel like you
have to at least acknowledge they have a
very engrained kind of family group you
know like the LP U has always been a
thing there's always been an ingrained
fanbase and it always feels at least
very intimate very much like a family
environment and I like that he chose to
exemplify that in just inviting the fans
who were you know around to catch that
Instagram post and who cared enough to
show up I think that's kind of exemplary
of the vibe Linkin Park puts out there
partly so yeah thanks for joining me
guys as always you can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell to get updated every time a
reviewer or videos out once again come
check us out on patreon if you want to
see the full uncut version of this video
and other sites and stuff that we're on
down in the description box and we will
see you on the next one
Cheers